i think we are in a moment of
transformation people are watching
movies on different devices
but ultimately it's all about the
freedom of creation and the fact that
people will be enjoying it in different
formats
i made a movie pmf in 1996 and i thought
it was an excellent starting point the
series doesn't feel like it's a remake
for him he loves to call it a
continuation of this film le von piero
was one of the best cereals ever by wifa
yard who was one of the pioneers of
french cinema and at the center of this
is musidora who was the original actress
it is quite extraordinary to go back to
1914 and see this character in her silk
catsuit and you realize all these famous
action characters or female villains it
suddenly seems like it was all inspired
from this one character
the ghost of arma webb has been haunting
cinema ever since my first intuition was
to go to someone who i admired very much
with nikola gasquier the designer for
louis vuitton and i wanted him to
reinvent the catsuit for our time
at the beginning we spoke with nikolao
about the materials because they had to
be sensual and enigmatic and not too
difficult for her to play with
i knew that i would have to create this
character from a very physical point to
stand out with this kind of costume
[Music]
i did some music for the vampire ballet
and i worked really closely with a
choreographer he would choreograph to
these rhythms that was sending him
i was really honored who worked with
angela crekas the choreographer and i
had the chance to rehearsal with him and
to do the scene because he plays his own
character on the film
one of the blessing of this project is
the locations are so gorgeous that it's
going to be excellent when you have the
right location the set becomes alive and
all of a sudden that scene becomes
stronger
we did a casting of rooftop in paris it
was unbelievable
olivier capture it in a magic way in a
way i rediscovered paris
the production design really helped
everyone to be immersed in our
environment
the main thing for me was to invent
something based on fairiad but more
modern
maybe more fun
it enriches the sets in such a way that
i feel it's not a set i feel like this
is just a part of the world
that's the magic of the worlds you
create and you step into
sets are an imitation of reality
just like dreams
whatever i write to me is the starting
point i don't want to hear the pages of
my screenplay turning i want to be the
first viewer of something we are
inventing together
[Music]
you